bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette édition spéciale du journal de la
rédaction nous allons revenir sur les
événements climatiques de ces derniers
jours avec la décrue de la scène l'heure
est au bilan nous verrons justement quel
est ce bilan avec nos invités dans un
instant mais tout d'abord quelques mots
concernant le déplacement jeudi soir du
ministre de l'intérieur dont les
yvelines bernard cazeneuve était à
marly-le-roi pour l'inauguration des
nouveaux locaux du centre de déminage
plusieurs annonces dans le cadre du plan
déminage 2020 et des moyens
supplémentaires seront alloués et
concernant l'euro de football
elle les agents seront fortement
mobilisés on écoute le ministre au micro
de william l vous serez bien sûr tout
particulièrement sollicités dans le
cadre de l'euro 2016 puisque vous aurez
la responsabilité de sécuriser
l'ensemble des stades et des fans zone
mais aussi des camps de base des hôtels
de transfert et des moyens de transport
utilisés par les équipes qui
participeront à cet événement sportif
d'ampleur internationale
j'ajoute que durant toute la durée de la
compétition
des démineurs issus de pays participants
notamment l'italie et l'espagne
viendront également nous prêter leur
concours et en force des équipes
j'ai également pris la décision de vous
autoriser à porter une arme
dans le cadre de vos missions comme vos
collègues policiers
vous intervenez très souvent sur des
situations complexes dans des
circonstances difficiles souvent hostile
et tout comme vous pouvez être la cible
de la haine et de la violence au simple
motif que vous porter l'uniforme et que
par là même vous incarnez la force
publique que vous incarnez l'état de
droit
le point complet sur ce déplacement du
ministre dans notre édition de lundi dès
18h en direct pour le moment ce sont
donc les inondations qui vont nous
intéresser au cours de cette édition
spéciale du
journal avec cinq invités autour de
cette table bernard coste aglio gars que
vous êtes le directeur territorial
donner 10 anciennement erdf dirhams rdf
pour peut-être plus de simplicité au
cours de cette édition on va parler de
l'alimentation électrique pendant ces
intempéries avec vous vous occupez du
département des yvelines face à vous
benoît noble vous êtes manager en
prévention des risques délégué à la
sécurité civile sur la commune des longs
cours notamment raphaël déjà expert e
reg zoo vous intervenez pour les pour
les assurances lorsque vous êtes
sollicités pour allait expertiser les
personnes qui ont été sinistrées pascal
rodier secrétaire général du secours
populaire dans les yvelines et alexandre
ruesch vous êtes président du syndicat
des jeunes agriculteurs de la région
ile-de-france bonsoir à tous les cinq
ans petit rappel des faits tout d'abord
mardi à 31 mais de fortes pluies
s'abattent sur l'île de france notamment
sur le département des yvelines pour les
pompiers les interventions se
multiplient l'autoroute a10 et notamment
coupé près de saint-arnoult des
établissements scolaires sont évacuées
la situation ne fait qu'empirer au cours
des jours suivants rambouillet la vallée
de chevreuse sont durement touché
pendant ce temps le niveau de la cn
augmente plus de 6 mètres du jamais vu
depuis plus de trente ans ces derniers
jours la situation revient
progressivement à la normale seulement
les dégâts sont nombreux l'heure est au
bilan et on va commencer avec vous
justement bernard costagliola vous êtes
directeur territorial je le disais
donner 10 anciennement erdf dans les
yvelines avant même déjà de faire le
bilan va peut-être rappeler que
l'électricité n'est pas tout à fait
rétabli pour tout le monde dans le
département aujourd'hui j'ai une bonne
nouvelle annoncée hier soir il ya
maintenant depuis depuis depuis midi les
derniers clients qui étaient privés
d'électricité inondées sur l'île verte
au large de masi et 2 et 2
didier ont retrouvé le courant vous avez
pu intervenir il fallait attendre que
les conditions de sécurité notamment
soient soient réunies on va voir
quelques unes des photos vous avez pu le
prendre
on nous avait fait part tenir leur
parvenir lors de vos interventions et on
va expliquer tout à l'heure comment vous
avez travaillé plus en détail mais
globalement si on fait un bilan
combien d'agents mobilisés combien de
foyers aussi toucher ces inondations a
tempéré ont représenté quoi pour vous
alors avant de repos dans votre question
je voulais d'abord souligner les
excellentes collaboration avec les
différents services en charge de la
gestion de de cet événement cru que ce
soit la préfecture que ce soit les le
conseil départemental ce soit les
communes qui souvent mis en place des pc
de crise que ce soit les sapeurs
pompiers la protection civile les
services de sécurité nous avons
travaillé en étroite collaboration avec
eux en toute intelligence et un lien
permanent c'est ça qui est que les
personnes ne doit a été à la tête ça a
été efficace et surtout l'exercice de
cru qu'on avait fait au mois de mars
dernier sous l'égide du préfet de région
et du préfet de département a été bien
utile dans l'organisation et la gestion
de cet événement alors posé la question
de ce qui s'est passé on a eu d'abord un
rappel c'est une évidence peut-être pour
beaucoup de monde mais l'électricité
n'est pas compatible avec l'eau et donc
lorsqu'on a des inondations il faut en
amont lorsque le phénomène de crues
apparaît que l'on puisse sécuriser les
installations électriques
que ce soit sur le réseau mais également
au domicile des particuliers
et puis en phase de décrue il faut
évidemment avant de remettre le courant
il faut qu'on vérifie que toutes les
installations soit propre qu'il n'y ait
pas de court circuit et y compris chez
des chez les clients chez dans les
foyers après ce rappel on a eu deux
événements sur les yvelines un premier
événement
vous le rappeliez sur rambouillet
l'yvette avec saint rémy les chevreuse
également la vallée de la mauldre il ya
eu des inondations
ça a touché à peu près 2000 foyers qui
ont été inondées et donc privés
d'électricité et il y avait seize
communes qui ont été concernés et
l'ensemble des clients ont été
réalimentés dans les 48 heures
même plus vite lorsque la décrue était
était là ce qui représente combien
d'agents mobilisés
est-ce que les et nous avions gens sont
les agents supplémentaires
on a mobilisé toutes nos ressources
delà de la région ile de france ouest
sur le
et on a on avait également mobiliser nos
propres groupes électrogènes un groupe a
d'ailleurs été mis en service sur la
commune de rambouillet pour alimenter
des foyers si on regarde cette question
du bilan j'ai moi aussi comme qu'on vous
entendre alexandre vais-je puisque vous
êtes le président du syndicat des jeunes
agriculteurs de la région ile de france
on verra tout à l'heure des des
particuliers qui ont été fortement
fortement impacté mais pour les
agriculteurs les champs aussi ont été
sinistrées quel est le bilan dans
département sur cette région
ile-de-france alors le bilan est très
lourd pour des zones assez ponctuelle
des surtout en vallée de seine où des
spécialisé donc sur des productions type
maraîchage ont été totalement inondées
donc une perte totale de quasi totale
pour certaines exploitations de leurs
futures récoltes parce que toutes les
terres étaient semer planter donc la
décrue s'est amorcée mais après plus
d'une semaine de soldes noyer tout est
perdu
le gros souci sur ces exploitations là
c'est que sont des exploitations
pourvoyeur de main d'oeuvre donc des
salariés au chômage technique donc des
mises en place de dispositifs pour avoir
du chômage technique et partielle qui
vont se traduire la enfin début de
semaine prochaine normalement
voilà le la situation est pour ces
exploitations est très très lourde et
c'est ces terres étaient inondés à
certains moments sur les périodes
hivernales où il n'y avait pas de
plantation est donc là c'était
supportable mais dans cette période là
c'est vraiment le pic de production et
donc c'est fatal pour ces exploitations
et les agriculteurs fortement fortement
touché le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines pierre bédier
a annoncé qu'une subvention
exceptionnelle de la chambre
d'agriculture d'île de france allait
être soumise au vote le 17 juin prochain
avant de vous faire réagir justement je
vous propose d'écouter les différentes
déclarations de pierre bédier avec ce
reportage de famille borgia
des parcelles ravagé des récoltes
catastrophiques
ici aux alentours de vernouillet les
inondations n'ont pas fait de cadeau aux
maraîchers le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines pierre bédier
s'est rendu sur place ce mercredi pour
soutenir ces agriculteurs en détresse
c'est important d'autant plus important
de les aider que c'est de leur part très
courageux parce que leurs discussions
c'est pas indemnisé nous leurs
discussions c'est aidez nous à
travailler société où le travail n'est
plus une valeur centrale avoir des gens
qui disent
aidez nous à travailler c'est un peu
normal qu'on se mobilise pour eux cet
agriculteur a vu 32 c 32 hectares être
une ondée la semaine dernière on estime
aujourd'hui son préjudice à 500000 euros
excédés par le manque de réactivité de
l'état peu de solutions s'offrent à lui
moi j'ai évoqué éventuellement le dépôt
de bilan
première solution c'est un outil de
gestion pour éventuellement redémarrer
soit une cessation d'activité ou
soulagerait relancer avec le concours je
dirais de l'état si l'état nous amène
des mesurettes
comme je ré comme d'habitude parce qu'on
les connaît les recettes il ressortait
même c'est pas une solution
sauver les emplois et les récoltes de
ces maraîchers
c'est l'objectif que s'est fixé le
département une subvention
exceptionnelle à la chambre
d'agriculture d'île de france sera
soumise au vote le 17 vent trop chaud
alexandre rush tout ça c'est va dans le
bon sens ce sont des déclarations que
vous soulevez cette base
aujourd'hui on je peux que saluer la
volonté après on ne connaît pas les
résultats
là on a rencontré aussi les élus de la
région de conseil régional pour voir
quelles sont les dispositions à mettre
en place il y a un souhait de faire de
mettre en place
le dispositif rebond à la région qui
n'était pas aujourd'hui éligibles
jusqu'à présent pour les agriculteurs
qui va le devenir a priori des annonces
de budgets débloqués pour pouvoir
subvenir aux exploitations aux
exploitants en suite de cet épisode là
ce qu'on attend en tant que
professionnel c'est que l'on puisse voir
l'avenir plus sereinement et réfléchira
aux futurs devenir de ces épisodes là et
on se rend bien compte que des épisodes
pluvieux maintenant sont des structures
ans pour nos exploitations et il faut
qu'on crée un fonds de garantie pour
pouvoir pallier à ces difficultés là
régionalement mais en termes de
prévention est ce que ce genre
d'événement on pouvait l'anticiper est
ce que en tout cas les choses étaient
prévues pour limiter les dégâts
alors je ne suis pas que tout ce qu'ils
avaient à anticiper ces épisodes laon
ont su le faire mais il ya un moment où
on ne peut pas lutter contre la nature
et la montée des eaux donc on a des
zones
on travaille sur des zones inondables
des zones d'expansion on aura
malheureusement de deux nouveaux
épisodes
benoît noble justement c'est peut-être
vous faire réagir vous qui êtes
spécialiste de cette question de la de
prévention des risques aussi est ce
qu'il y avait des choses à faire qui
n'ont pas été faites que ce soit là on
parle des agriculteurs mais il n'ya pas
que les agriculteurs on va tout faire
moi aussi pour les particuliers alors
avant de répondre d'abord je voudrais
rappeler que sur une épisode et de crise
on a trois phases la phase
d'anticipation la compréhension de ce
qui peut nous arriver
ensuite la phase d'action au moment de
la crise ce qu'on appelle la crise et
puis ensuite ce que vous connaissez bien
le plan de continuité d'activité
c'est-à-dire le retour à la normale donc
on peut appeler aussi nous dans le
jargon de spécialistes la résilience
donc oui on peut se prémunir de certains
événements dont certains on ne peut pas
en prémunir les événements lourds
une crue subite je crois bien une crue
subite papale anticipée de la prémunir
enfin là la voir arriver les trombes
d'eau qui sont tombées sur le territoire
francilien il ya quelques jours il ya
une dizaine de jours on parlait pour
certains territoires comme trappe 284
litres au mètre carré
c'est énorme et si on fait le calcul de
la surface du bassin parisien
mais là je rentre pas dans les détails
de bassins versants etc ou d'agriculture
on pourra en reparler après je ne
voulais pas le propre
on a plein de choses à faire en amont se
préparer alors préparez la population
préparer les agriculteurs préparer les
ce qu'on appelle les opérateurs
d'importance vitale mais pour moi une
seule salle ce ne sont pas que les
grands les grandes entreprises comme edf
ou erdf c'est aussi les assureurs les
agriculteurs les agriculteurs c'est le
grenier de la france l'agriculteur au
fait comment et donc pour en revenir à
cette histoire de ces problématiques de
crue il faut savoir que pas tous les
sept ans on augmente la superficie de
territoire rendu imperméable de la
taille d'un département français
donc aujourd'hui il va falloir faire une
machine arrière très rapidement sinon ça
va s'accentuer par la dea perméabilité à
sion des sols il y a des tas de
solutions financières et techniques
donc je vais pas rentrer dans le détail
ce serait trop long mais ça existe donc
temps pour les communes que pour les
opérateurs ou pour les les entreprises
et puis les agriculteurs bien que j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour eux en étant
moi même d'une famille d'agriculteurs
on peut peut-être retourner à ce que
faisaient nos anciens remettre en état
les fossés qui vont permettre de faire
des drainages immédiat en cas d'épisode
accord
francis sur l'entretien des fossés à
cause d'une réglementation
environnementale ou en fait tout
agriculteur qui avant faisait comment
avec son bon sens l'entretien de ces
fossés aujourd'hui peut se voir
pénaliser même mis au pilori par la
police de l'eau tout à fait alors je
rebondis ce sont sur ce que dit monsieur
certaines personnes de bonne volonté
vont curé un réseau existant donc un
fossé et dernièrement un homme s'est vu
condamné parce qu'ils avaient cure est
un faux c'est parce que tu es
l'association j'ai rien contre les
associations bien évidemment puisque je
fais aussi partie du parc associatifs
tels associations défendent l avis de je
ne sais quel animal qui est sympathique
au demeurant mais à un moment il va
falloir privilégié l'animal on peut le
déplacer l'exploitation agricole ou la
ferme qui existe depuis 300 ans on ne
peut pas la déplacer donc déjà il va
falloir se remettre dans l'état d'esprit
que cette crise était importante certes
mais ce n'était pas une crise majeure
donc il faut se préparer à la crise rien
à voir p a effectivement il faut bien
payer la source qu'elle est dingue pour
l'agriculture je préconise bien
évidemment et ça cela l'état doit
légiférer de façon responsable et
définitives et ne pas se cacher derrière
son petit loin en disant oui maintenant
on va curé il y aurait donné les moyens
et pareil nous avons des solutions aux
économique sans augmenter les impôts je
vous rassure curer les fossés faire de
l'agriculture ce qu'on appelle de
l'agriculture en butée et que vous
connaissez bien qui permet cela
nécessite la création de sion ce qui
fait quand vous avez des ruissellements
il s'arrête au sillon et après vous avez
les fossés tampon vous réduisez le
déversement puisque 45% et là je parle à
quelqu'un qui navigue dans le domaine
des assurances de 45% des sinistrés en
france le sont par des phénomènes de
ruissellement
donc ces sinistrés justement on va on va
se rendre maintenant du côté de saint
rémy les chevreuse une commune qui a été
fortement touchée on doit parler à des
particuliers l'impact pour les
particuliers ce qui nous permettra
effectivement de voir comment les
experts interviennent et comment la
solidarité s'est organisée aussi le
reportage de camille lambert pour auprès
des sinistrés pour constater les dégâts
mais on voit bien le niveau le niveau
toujours pensé y avait des le savons
qu'elle
le salon de récits qui a percé envoie la
tresse c'est ça semble à regarder mais
je laissais je ferai un témoin le 31 mai
roland a eu sa maison inondée suite aux
fortes pluies l'eau s'est infiltrée par
ses aérations
une semaine plus tard les traces sont
toujours visibles sur les murs et le
souvenir encore vif j'étais confiant
jamais jean ainsi causer une montée
aussi bouge aussi rapides et importants
ça c'était inimaginable
ça fait 60 ans je suis là réfrigérateurs
cuisinières machine à laver plus rien ne
fonctionne
il espère être indemnisées rapidement
pour s'équiper à nouveau et entamer des
travaux dans la rue chez nos de saint
rémy les chevreuse ils sont nombreux
comme lui à compter leurs pertes
philippe a seulement eu sa cave inondée
mais la chaudière a été endommagée donc
voilà l'eau est montée à peu près
j'étais auteurs la chaudière donc le
brûleur qui étaient branchés ici
et immerger encore en usage il attend
encore la visite de l'expert pour
estimer si d'autres pièces ont été
touchés des outils sont également
inutilisable philippe estime à environ
3000 euros de pertes
au total il est confiant quant à la
prise en charge des réparations et
souligner le soutien des habitants
on n'a pas de chauffage d'eau pas de
douche on se douche chez les voisins
voilà je trouvais qu'il y avait une très
belle solidarité entre les voisins
en ce qui nous concerne on a énormément
aidé ceux qui étaient plus touchés que
nous tous les soirs on faisait un repas
en commun pour un peu pour vider les
congélateurs d'une part et puis aussi
pour se réconforter les uns les autres
en phase manuelle travaille depuis huit
jours pour remettre en ordre sa maison
concernant l'assurance
il est un peu perdu tout ça parce que
bon il a pas encore passé à côté on sait
pas encore mais aussi sommé azul et je
comprends rien
jeudi 9 juin saint rémy les chevreuse
n'était pas encore reconnues en état de
catastrophe naturelle une seconde
commission aura lieu mercredi 15 juin si
la commune et bien déclarée les
assureurs devront indemniser les
victimes pour les dégâts matériels
causés par les inondations
la ville a déjà reçu 200 dossiers de
sinistrés comme pour manuel le 31 mai
2016 restera une date gravée dans leur
mémoire
57 communes ont été déclarées en état de
catastrophe naturelle il en était
question dans ce reportage on va en voir
là la liste voilà tout de suite qui
s'affiche à l'écran pendant que je me
tourne vers rafael des jarres experts
pour la société exo tâte répondre à
quelques interrogations aussi qu'ils
sont qui ce qu'on a pu entendre là dans
ce reportage on voit des gens qui sont
souvent perdus quand on retourne dans
son logement
on se dit il va falloir faire venir sans
doute un expert quel est le premier
réflexe à avoir il faut pas tout jeter
il faut garder est retrouvé des papiers
c'est aussi compliqué qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire dans cette situation
alors il faut
j'ai déjà prévenir les gens pour les
rassurer l'expert va arriver mais des
choses peuvent être faites en amont donc
il n'a pas mais on n'a pas besoin de
tout concert l'expert n'a pas besoin de
tout voir pour chiffrer les dommages
ça c'est la première chose donc si des
mesures d'urgence pour des questions
d'hygiène ou même de sécurité la
nécessite le déblaiement ou là en tout
cas le retire dans des gravats ou de des
biens endommagés
il est possible de le faire par contre
il faut que les assurés prennent en
photo leurs dommages et des preuves un
petit peu factuel a présenté lors du
passage de l'expert le ce qu'il faut
communément faire en avance de l'
expertise pour faciliter à la fois
l'indemnisation est à la fois le travail
de l'expert ces deux via un état de
pertes ce qu'on appelle nous dans le
jargon d'état pertes qui en fait un
listing exhaustif de l'an l'intégralité
des biens endommagés
que ce soit le contenu et le bâtiment
lors du passage de l'expert sur ce
dernier va faire le va chez qui les
points 1 1 avec avec le sinistre est il
derrière
seront ils pour ensuite réaliser son
rapport pour l'indemnisation auprès de
sa compagnie d'assurance
on me disait aussi d'autres méthodes qui
se développe ça peut se faire par vidéo
tafer web interposés en fait l'ensemble
des réseaux d expertise aujourd'hui en
tout cas du coup je le précise un peu
pour la société oryx haut en effet nous
avons développé des solutions
d'expertisé alternative nous avons pas
besoin de faire passer un expert sur
place
la prestation des expertises peut se
réaliser soit par téléphone directement
avec l'assuré et auquel cas ce dernier
va nous transmettent les pièces par mail
par courrier et par fax et tous les
moyens que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
voire même par visio expertise avec le
téléchargement d'une application alors
le ski est un petit peu compliqué dans
le cadre des inondations ce type de
prestations aux visions s'il n'y a pas
d'électricité pas de boxe pas de réseau
et voilà donc c'est mais en tout cas
voilà il ya déjà des moyens alternatifs
pour faciliter la vie des assurés pour
avoir une prise en charge rapide de la
part de compagnies d'assurance et bien
évidemment une remise en état avant
sinistre vous vous intervenez lorsque
les compagnies d'assurance vous
sollicite vous allez voir les
particuliers qui ont été qui ont été
sinistrées enfin je rajoute particuliers
entreprises collectivités on intervient
pour vraiment justement combien d'agents
sont mobilisés aujourd'hui et comment
vous avez vous de votre côté a fait face
à la demande
alors pour inscrire au plus vite les
dossiers parce que c'est aussi la
demande d'aidé lance français que ça
évite cet événement climatique en fête a
eu lieu sur deux grandes régions qui
sont la région ile de france et le
centre
donc on va parler principalement la
région ile de france en temps normal on
a on a approximativement 100 experts en
moyenne lorsque pour traiter les
dossiers s'étendant trimestre de
fréquences avec cet afflux mission on a
évidemment active de notre cellule de
gestion des événements exceptionnels qui
permet à d'apporter sur l'ensemble du
territoire français
des experts en renfort sur le la région
sinistrée et aujourd'hui on est à 35
experts en renfort je tiens à souligner
majoritairement du sud-ouest et du
sud-est puis le
je pense que tout le monde autour du
plateau le en est conscient il ya eu des
événements début de semaine dans le nord
et l'est
donc voilà nous sommes les réseaux
d'expertisé
sommes nous sommes bien mobilisés a
posteriori évidemment des interventions
des opérateurs des opérateurs principaux
ainsi que des services de secours et des
forces de police mme pascale redirai
pour le secours populaire vous aussi
vous avez été fortement mobilisés parce
qu avant même d'attendre les experts de
pouvoir être remboursés
il faut vivre aussi au quotidien il faut
que la solidarité s'organise oui alors
c'est vrai que pour les yvelines on n'a
pas été aussi sollicitée que la seine et
marne et l'essonne mais en tant que
réseau de solidarité ce qui nous faut
combiner c'est la réponse une
proposition de solidarité avec les gens
qui spontanément souhaite aider il ya
sept ce paramètre là et puis il ya les
gens qui ont besoin d'être aidés et donc
sur ces deux vecteurs là en fait on
essaye d'identifier les familles qui
sont habituellement aidées par le
secours populaire pour savoir si elles
ont été touchées affectées par les
inondations puisque c'est vers les
personnes que l'on est déjà vu qu'on
connaît leur situation qu'on va se
tourner et puis après il est possible
que sur la demande d'intervention d'un
crs d'un centre communal d'action
sociale on puisse être amené aussi à
voir ce que l'on peut faire donc soit
pour des dépannages ponctuels soit
éventuellement pour une aide au
rééquipement des foyers et donc sur ses
volets là nous on a besoin d'argent et
donc du coup on fait donc
on a fait un appel aux dons et avec ces
fonds collectés on va sur dossier
proposer des équipements en articles de
première nécessité comme notamment tout
ce qui est le chauffage et la machine à
laver fin des choses tu réponds très
précises pour que les gens puissent
réelles entamer une vie normale et que
ça puisse se faire aussi alors il ya un
autre élément aussi c'est que on a beau
être assurée quand on a des de
l'électroménager vieux et tout ça en
fait en termes de remboursement
c'est peu remboursés et quand vous êtes
au minima sociaux voire en dessous des
minima
ben ça devient quand même très compliqué
de réinvestir dans un frigo ou dans 1
dans une machine à laver et donc à ce
moment-là on intervient souvent parce
par ce biais là en fait en apportant du
matériel qu'on a acheté grâce à la
générosité des donateurs lors des
différentes interventions que vous avez
pu faire avec le secours populaire il ya
une bonne coordination entre les
différents services allaient refaire
représentants des municipalités par
exemple si vous êtes sur la ville
d'elancourt sur l'association une
importance vitale
ce sont les gens se contourne est ce
qu'il ya c'est que en fait après ça va
dépendre des villes et du degré de
d'implication on va dire d'imprégnation
pour utiliser un terme des associations
dans les circuits d'urgence c'est à dire
que toutes les associations nous par
exemple longtemps que secours populaire
on n'est pas sur le même registre que la
croix rouge ou la sécurité civile par
exemple
donc on va intervenir souvent sur des
dépannages par exemple dans la ville
d'epône les amis du secours populaire de
mantes la ville ont été sollicités pour
apporter du matériel de première
nécessité pour les gens qui étaient
hébergés dans le gymnase
donc là ça se fait sur les stocks moi
dire existants du du comité local et
puis après sur le département des civils
on n'a pas de bénévoles qui sont allés à
proprement parler au nom du secours
populaire j'entends peut-être capacités
individuelles et l'oncfs et nettoie
aider à nettoyer mais ça c'est ça s'est
fait sur le 77 par exemple où ils ont eu
lieu y compris leurs propres locaux dans
certains endroits touchés
jusqu'où aller c'est quand même une
association qui existe depuis 1945 deux
meilleurs 88 la fin 81 quelques 1000
bénévoles les associations tout confondu
secours populaire croix rouge protection
civile etc sont le socle de la paix
sociale en france
j'ai la tendance à dire que c'est
toujours là que le quatrième pilier de
la république pas d'association en
france gros problème social derrière
vous avez les secours 90% des secours en
france sont bénévoles ou volontaire faut
savoir si on les a plus on fait quoi de
20 donc d'où le danger est là la
sensibilisation que nous souhaitons
faire et lui
heureusement je suis aidé par monsieur
bédié par monsieur fourgous et par
monsieur favier mais sans eux
un élu local ne peut ne peut rien faire
il y a la volonté d'avancer
nous sommes là pour les aider à se
former et à se sensibiliser sur toutes
les méthodes qui existent pour aller de
l'avant
utilisons comme vous le disiez toute la
transversalité et on en vient
échantillons ici pour ne faire un tour
de table est avancé mais pas seulement
sur le plan politique sur un plan global
macro nous arrive complètement la fin de
cette édition c'est malheureusement trop
court avec tout ce qui est à dire et les
nombreux intervenants qui ont gentiment
accepté de devenir donner un peu de leur
temps alors qu'ils sont tous mobilisés
j'aurais tout de même qu'on revienne sur
le travail qui a été mené côté de la
remise en service
électrique aussi parce que on parlait
tout à l'heure de prévention des
différents plans est ce qu un plan
d'intervention existait déjà en quoi il
consiste est-ce que tout a bien
fonctionné nous avons nous avions
effectivement tout l'heure où il avait
signalé un des maîtres mots c'est de
l'anticiper de ce type des mamans nous
avions un plan de prévention pour
anticiper nous avions mobilisé notamment
dans la deuxième phase 2 de crue la crue
de la seine nous avions mobilisé la
force d'intervention rapide électricité
sur des collègues d'autres régions qui
sont venus nous aider
une trentaine de collègues de poitou
charentes de bretagne qui sont venus
nous prêter renfort avec des groupes
électrogènes avec du matériel donc nous
étions prêts un événement qui fort
heureusement vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure a été moins moins grave que ce
qu'il a été mais nous étions prêts à
faire face à un élève je vous interromps
c'est bien que vous ayez utiliser cette
force d'action rapide qui pour le commun
des mortels est une forme usine et
surtout au nucléaire a protégé le
nucléaire et c'est bien que vous l'ayez
utilisé dans ce type de situation non
non c'est pas pour le nucléaire on la
fera pas l'argent raconte c'est une
forme d'intervention l'attention des les
10 qui permet de mobiliser des
ressources très rapidement de toute la
france c'est bien de l a été mobilisé à
cette occasion l'aide
forte heureusement elle n'a pas été
utile mais pour autant nous étions prêts
nous avions implanter des groupes dans
les sites sensibles des communes la ou
les gymnases où on est les communes
avaient envisagé de d'évacuer les
personnes dont tout était prêt pour donc
ça c'est important et puis surtout ce
que je souhaitais signaler c'est la
prévention que nous avons essayé de
faire tout au long de cet événement par
médias télévision presse site internet
des petits flyers dans les boîtes aux
lettres la prévention auprès de
l'ensemble des foyers pour leur
expliquer ce que j'ai dit tout à leur
lot électricité t'es pas bon ménage il
ya un certain de précaution à prendre
que les onglets donc pourquoi
l'électricité revient pas forcément haut
du jour au lendemain lorsque elle tombe
enfin l'heure seulement qu on coupe
l'électricité le gaz et quand boulot et
quand on revient dans le logement il
faut qu'on fasse tous les contrôles et
enée disent on est là pour accompagner
les plats sécurité soit clair c'est
contre on respecte et je passe au mieux
et justin derniers mois en 20 secondes
vous souhaitez intervenir à l'exemple le
ruissellement c'est vrai que cette année
à l'approché de cet épisode pluvieux les
sols étaient déjà très pourvu en eau
donc aucune capacité à boire donc
ruissellement tout de suite d'office et
donc par rapport à ça et ce qu'a dit
monsieur sur la perméabilité des sols
avec l'urbanisation
il est nécessaire qu aujourd'hui étant
donné que on se rend bien compte que les
terres agricoles sont peuvent être en
tout cas la variable d'ajustement dans
cas d'inondation et donc il faut qu'on
trouve une solution pour pouvoir
pérenniser ces exploitants qui sont dans
des zones sensibles à risque
voilà c'est ça l'objectif de travail à
l'avenir avec la région merci une
nouvelle fois tous les 5 et d'être
d'être venu il y avait encore beaucoup
de choses à dire et on aura sans doute
voilà l'occasion de vous faire revenir
pour en parler on va vous laisser
retourner travailler maintenant parce
que le temps est précieux merci beaucoup
de nous avoir suivi également cette
édition est à voir en replay sur notre
site internet et on se retrouve lundi
pour un nouveau journal en direct à 18h